hier ist kein analytischer aufbau
sondern eine abfolge von von
parlamentarischen darstellung okay
der ansatz ist dass wir benjamins
gedanken zurückführen auf philosophische
grundlagen die er nur bedingt deutlich
macht die drehen sehe ich also jetzt
jedenfalls würde ich vorschlagen als als
mittel zur annäherung die drehen sich um
den begriff der bilder ist also bild ist
für benjamin ein fundamentaler begriff
und es gibt zwei sorten von bildern bei
benjamin es gibt dialektische bilder und
es gibt archaische bilder und dement ist
sehr bestrebt diese beiden voneinander
fernzuhalten wenn sie beispielsweise im
passagenwerk auf seite 5 178 der
gesammelten schriften band 5 dann werden
sie sehen
da geht es um ein
eine thematik die wir schon hatten
nämlich dass jetzt der erkennbarkeit
also die fragestellung ist wie versteht
der geschichte schreiben
die vergangenheit was macht der
historiker überhaupt mit der
vergangenheit
und was hat das überdies hinaus hat das
was hat das mit politisch positiven
handlungen zu tun
also wir wollen jetzt nicht sagen
unbedingt marxistisch oder revolutionär
oder links oder was auch immer aber die
frage ist was macht der historiker wenn
er oder sie eine positive einen
positiven zugang zur geschichte
herstellt grundlage dafür wie bin sagt
benjamin ist ist die das aufbrechen des
containers also der historiker muss erst
mal verstehen verstanden haben dass die
geschichte kein kontinuum ist sondern
ist es immer nur also echt historie
echte geschichte ist ein aufbrechen des
kontinuums und ein eintauchen in das
jetzt einer bestimmten erkennbarkeit
also das was der echte historiker jetzt
produkt auf produktive weise erkennt ist
immer nur ein abgeschlossener bereich es
nicht quasi eine
ein gesehen kein gesetz mäßiger fluss
von aus der vergangenheit hierher der
uns voran treibt also dieses das bild
des fortschrittes sondern wir erinnern
uns an ein bestimmtes also in diesem
jetzt erinnern wir uns an eine bestimmte
vorgänge aus der geschichte und das war
diese diese sache mit der rache also für
benjamin ist das ist die geschichte des
rechen rache bringt also das sind für
ihn die die begriffe und aber was da
erkannt wird ist eben ein bild gut also
bewegen sie sich seite 5 178 anschauen
das ist ein abschnitt aus dem
erkenntnistheoretischen teil oder
komplett des wasserwerks dann sagt er
also das ist wichtig weil ein bild kann
auch für benjamin rückständig oder
negativ oder oder was auch immer
also nicht positiv seien der historiker
kann schon eine bestimmte erkennbarkeit
wahrnehmen und die allein die tatsache
dass ihnen das gelingt bedeutet nicht
dass das dann auf als politisch wertvoll
es ist ja sagt nämlich zunächst mal
gesagt es gibt zwei arten von bildern
die elektrische und der ist eingriffe
die andere sorte ist archaisch gibt
dialektische bilder und archaische
bilder ja und das hat nur dialektische
bilder sind echt geschichtliche dh nicht
archaische
ok also der historiker arbeitet mit
bildern aus der vergangenheit
es gibt und eine positiv ein positiver
umgang mit dieser vergangenheit ist
dialektisch negativ hingegen oder das
was ebenfalls das phänomen ablehnt ist
das arbeiten mit archaischen bildern
ja okay das ist jetzt hier die
fragestellung wenn ihm endlich den
fortschritt gedanken ob also geschichte
ist kein keine abfolge von gesetzlich
gesetzmäßig miteinander verknüpften
ereignissen sondern es ist ein zurück
tauchen in irgendwelche auf wie man den
bildern
okay das ist das eine aber es gibt zwei
möglichkeiten mit diesen bildern es gibt
dialektische bildern es gibt ein
spanischer bilder ok und unsere frage
erst mal ist was ist der unterschied
weil mit dieser unterscheidung im
hintergrund seiner fragestellungen zum
zu pari ist ist ja ist es nicht nur so
quasi eine beschreibung so ein
historisches bilderbuch sondern die
frage ist was ist politisch sinnvolles
engagement das ist die fragestellung so
zu den pariser überlegungen und der
grund warum er diese
etwas seltsamen figuren oder seltsam
anmutenden figuren den den hells den
intriganten den sozialisten usw alles
ist die frage stellt ja ok wie sollen
wir hier handeln
das wäre jetzt angewandt auf unsere
heutige zeit
was wäre das das entsprechende und bude
leer ist wie gesagt ein scheitert in
diesem zusammenhang und die
fragestellung ist warum scheiterte er in
paris des 19 jahrhunderts gibt es
diverse formen politischen engagement
eine form wird durch butter vertreten
aber die ist offensichtlich gescheitert
warum
ok jetzt mit den bildern dann die
erkenntnis theoretische hintergrund das
möchte ich jetzt noch mal ein bisschen
durch arbeiten weil die philosophischen
quellen sind wichtig und und benjamin
appelliert an diese quellen manchmal
ausdrücklich aber genauso oft nur
implizit erkenntnistheoretische frage
ist was es wahrheit anders ausgedrückt
was ist die basis der gewissheit sowas
ist gewissheit
wann weiß ich oder wann bin ich
überzeugt dass etwas wahr ist und nicht
falsch das ist die klassische frage und
da gibt es zwei möglichkeiten das hatten
wir schon angesprochen aber ich habe es
jetzt nochmal ebenfalls aus aus aus
sicht der benjamin benni menschen
perspektive gibt es zum einen
den platte und platonischen anzug oder
sagen wir den nationalistischen ansatz
und der wird stark attackiert zu beginn
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts von vielen
leuten aber was ist jetzt dieser
nationalistische ansatz
es ist der vor allem natürlich der
glaube an die zukunft und an fortschritt
und so weiter zukunft gerichtet wäre die
erkenntnis und auch die aufgabe der der
menschen
grundlage dafür für die gewissheit
also woher wissen wir überhaupt es dass
wir voranschreiten in die zukunft etwas
belastbares herstellen können oder
wollen
der gedanke ist dass die sicherheit oder
die gewissheit liegt im begrifflich also
wie letztes letzte woche schon
angesprochen
quasi die bestätigung für diese position
ist immer die arithmetik die arithmetik
das mal in meiner begrifflichkeit ich
streng logisch auch nachvollziehen und
beschreiben kann also wie die arithmetik
funktioniert siehe frage im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert
das ist immer die ultimative bestätigung
dafür dass das was in meinem kopf
abläuft begriffs mäßig auch in der
außenwelt genauso verankert ist
also da ist die gewissheit für diesen
ansatz belegt vor allem durch durch die
arithmetik von dieser also das ist etwas
wie gesagt dass das gerade
20 im frühen zwanzigsten jahrhundert
dann wieder ganz stark aufgearbeitet
wird von versuchen die vor allem pflege
der versucht zu zeigen dass die
arithmetik der reinen logik aus der
einen satz logik abgeleitet werden kann
und satz loki ist das was am engsten mit
den fähigkeiten des menschlichen der
menschlichen begrifflichkeit verwandt
ist und wenn das so ist dann besteht
eine verbindung zwischen wie gesagt den
inhalten meiner begrifflichen arbeit und
allem was da draußen ist okay das ist
frei im zwanzigsten jahrhundert ich
glaube nicht dass er das band regel
gelesen hat aber im hintergrund sind
noch weitere wichtige philosophen vor
allem natürlich leibnitz und beileid
netz leiten ist hat auch diese diese
diesen ehrgeiz gehabt
universelle berechnungsmethoden
aufzubauen also damals war die logik die
formelle logik nicht so weit entwickelt
dass es ihm jetzt nicht konkret gelungen
aber bleibt für leibnitz war der gedanke
wenn wir genug mathematiker haben dann
können wir alle probleme der welt
lösen also nicht nur die quasi
ingenieurs probleme oder probleme aus
der naturwissenschaft sondern auch
moralische probleme bleiben jetzt meint
es irgendwann werden wir so weit sein
dass wenn die ein moralisches problem
haben rechtsprobleme oder irgendwas dann
brauchen wir nur zu irgendeinem
kalkulatorischen modell zur zuzugreifen
und damit können wir dann die frage
klären meinte das ist heutzutage auch
kommt auch relativ oft vor in der
philosophie ist es ist es die theorie
des nationalen handelns also der gedanke
dass man schon ethische fragestellungen
drei bestellung formalisieren kann man
muss da nicht auf empfängen oder sonst
was zurückgreifen sondern man halt
einfach in der formel es gibt auch in
der juristerei den gedanken dass man
eigentlich auch juristische
streitigkeiten rechtsstreitigkeiten
formalisieren könnte derart dass man
quasi jetzt nicht morgen nicht mehr zum
richter gehen müsste bekanntlich sind
richter eigensinnig und man weiß nie so
genau was dabei rauskommt aber wenn man
quasi einen automaten hätte das wie
bustickets oder sonstwer ausspruch dann
geht mir einfach zum automaten und
drückt die entsprechenden knöpfe und
dann kommt die lösung für den
rechtsstreit also dieser gedanke das
sind alle
so quasi das sind die optimisten und die
fortschrittsgläubigen an die von denen
sich benjamin und viele anderen am
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
absetzt noch wichtiger ist dass das
beispiel für diese leibnitz einstellung
also wenn die welt also mathematik ist
das eine aber leiten jetzt geht weiter
ist das leid nicht sagt alles was in der
welt ist lässt sich durch allgemein
begriffe erfassen ja es ist klar dass
die welt an sich
unordentlich und schmuddelig ist und
nicht nach reinen begrifflichen
verhungerten sich zeigt sondern ist
einfach schrecklich
wie soll man so weit wie soll man nicht
mit einer solchen welt umgehen
leibnitz sagt das ist nur ein mangel an
daten und daten verarbeitungskapazität
wenn wir genug genügend daten haben dann
können wir alles was sich zeigt auf der
welt also alle erscheinungen überhaupt
zu bestimmten allgemeinen griffen zu
ordnen
ja also allgemein begriffe sind
aus stahl schwarz anderthalb meter hoch
und so weiter
das sind allgemein begriffe mit denen
ich dieses diese mikrofon stehen da
beschreiben könnte und ich muss nicht
zurück und sagen ich wüsste jedenfalls
nicht sagen ja ich weiß es nicht es ist
halt dieser mikrofonständer also das ist
keine allgemein brücke ein allgemein
bekanntes ist besteht allgemein begriffe
bestehen aus zuordnungen die allgemein
sind und wo ich nicht
zuflucht nehmen muss und dass hier zu
identifizieren indem ich sage ja ist es
halt hier dieser mikrofonständer das ist
nicht allgemein das ist spezifisch oder
partikular philosophisch ausgedrückt
subjektiv also subjektiv ist alles was
was eben nicht durch allgemeine begriffe
sich beschreiben lässt
leibnitz sagte in einem bekannten bild
als beispiel wenn man durch den
herbstlichen park geht liegen überall
liegt über laub auf dem boden
die blätter dem braunen blätter die
runter gefahren sind
also wenn man sich das anschaut würde
man zuerst denken wie soll ich ein blatt
von den anderen unterscheiden sich
wieder alle
es gibt viele vielleicht nicht unbedingt
identisch aber so ziemlich identisch
aber dann hätte ich beispielsweise zwei
blätter die ich schon einander nicht
unterscheiden kann oder nur dadurch
unterscheiden kann dass ich sagt also
ein blatt habe ich in der rechten hand
und ein blatt aber in der linken hand
aber das ist nur wie gesagt eine
subjektive unterscheidung es keine
unterscheidung durch objektive merkmale
aber leibnitzer das mag schon sein in
der praxis ist fällt es einem schwer die
beiden voneinander zu unterscheiden aber
wenn wir adäquate instrumente der
datenerfassung hätten beispielsweise
dann könnte man immer beliebige blätter
also jedes blatt von jedem anderen blatt
durch die zuschreibung von
allgemeingültigen von allgemeinen
begriffen voneinander unterscheiden
ja das ist letztes argument
okay das ist das also das ist versucht
leibnitz abzuleiten vom satz vom
ausgeschlossenen mittel oder vom
ausgeschlossenen fitter ist als vom
widerspruch also eher für leibnitz
versucht diese leibnitz das erfassen der
realität und damit der gewissheit
verknüpfen mit der tätigkeit des geistes
als logische maschine sozusagen also die
logische maschine arbeitet mit
allgemeinen begriffen und mit diesen
allgemeinen begriffen kann die logische
maschine wird sprich meinen kopf alles
erfassen und alle unterscheidungen
vornehmen das ist laut mäzens idee das
ist der eine punkt beileid mit der
andere punkt beileid netz wie sie
wahrscheinlich wissen ist einsatz vom
zureichenden grunde und der satz vom
zureichenden grunde besagt für alles was
es gibt es einen grund den wir
vielleicht auch nicht käme also genau
wie bei den blättern ich kann vielleicht
zwei blätter ich persönlich kann bin ich
in der lage zwei blättern voneinander zu
unterscheiden weil ich nicht genügend
verfüge nicht über genügend daten
beziehungsweise nicht über die adäquate
begriffe mit denen ich die blätter
beschreiben kann
das ist ein aspekt bei leibnitz der
andere aspekt bei leuten jetzt ist der
satz vom zureichenden grunde wo er sagt
ja alles hat einen grund und diesem
grund auch die den grund kennen oder
nicht macht jetzt keinen großen
unterschied grundsätzlich also
theoretisch muss es immer möglich sein
ein grund ausfindig zu machen oder green
kommt auch sie aus sich zu machen
gut also diese beiden sachen in
kombinationen bedeutenden im leibniz ins
weltbild dass man eine welt hat die
erschöpfend vollständig erklärt wird
durch logisch handhabbare element
nämlich begriffe erstens zweitens die
welt ist auch die in der form gestaltet
dass alles was in der welt geschieht
kausal verknüpft ist mit allem anderen
ja das ist eine zwingende logische
abfolge singen die welt ist logisch
erfassbar und auch die abläufe in der
welt historisch gesehen sind in einem
system zu verstehen ja jetzt fortschritt
und so weiter
fortschritt ist sache des philosophen
aber des wissenschaftlers für leibnitz
bei er ja oder sie abschätzen kann wo
die welt hin geht also wenn der
philosophie alles wissen würde dann
könnte der theoretische wie gott auch
vorher genau vorhersagen wo wir landen
werden morgen oder in einer woche oder
nächstes jahr oder was auch immer
das ist dem menschen natürlich verwehrt
aber das leid mäzens bild gottes ist
gerade derjenige der über eine solche
universelle kausalität waltet dass auf
der anderen seite spiegelverkehrt mit
diesem fortschrittsglauben ist natürlich
der gedanke dass der historiker
ebenfalls die kalte kausale abfolge aus
der vergangenheit nachverfolgt und
deswegen meine diese diesen ganzen diese
ganzen elemente die haben wir uns
gewissermaßen schon schon angeguckt aber
wie gesagt letztendlich wurzel haben sie
alle die gemeinsam awards in der
beantwortung der frage was es gewissheit
gewissheit ist also wenn man denn einen
sagen wir mal plateau nisten fragt was
ist jetzt gewissheit der ponys antwortet
gewissheit gibt es weil die welt mit dem
logischen
fakultäten des menschen korrespondiert
ja ich weiß es wird war ich meine ob
jetzt im einzelfall
der inhalt meines kopfes wahr oder
falsch ist es eine andere frage aber ich
habe jedenfalls die sicherheit dass eine
wahrheit möglich ist weil eben diese
dieser logischen verknüpfungen die wir
bei leuten ist gesehen haben existieren
oder existieren können ja das wäre
gewiss halt ok
dagegen gibt es in der gesamten
geschichte philosophie gegen wäre das
könnte einem also was ich jetzt gerade
beschrieben habe bei leighton ist könnte
gewissermaßen und selbstverständlich
einem vorkommen und es ist sicherlich
auch sehr eng verknüpft mit in der
neuzeit der universitären philosophie
das ist ein furchtbares hält für eine
institutionalisierte philosophie diese
leibnitzer geschichte also gerade
beschrieben haben
da gibt es bereiche die man die relativ
stabil sind und die man schön bearbeiten
kann auf dieser grundlage also bis hin
zur ästhetik und ethik oder logik oder
was auch immer
das sind abgesteckte bereich diese die
man also gruppen von begrifflichkeiten
sozusagen die der philosoph als
institutionalisierte forscher
bearbeiten kann aber es gab immer in der
so viele andere rebellische geist die
damit nicht direkt einverstanden war
und zwar wie es zurück in die antike
klassisch sind argumente gegen die
gesetzmäßigkeit oder die die erfassbar
kite der bewegung ja also das ist ist
ein element die paradoxien von zehn
unternehmen sind davon wichtiges
beispiel
denn wenn sie das interessiert dann
müssen sie das bitte selbst verfolgen
aber die bekannte die bekannten sind
oder bekannte paradoxie es
beispielsweise von achilles ag ließ der
schnelle läufer soll eine schildkröte
überholen und zehn und hat versucht zu
demonstrieren dass man das begrifflich
gar nicht erfassen kann oder dass
achilles dem die schildkröten ii wird
überholen können
das erfordert dass man immer kleiner
werdenden zeitabschnitte betrachtet und
in jedem zeitabschnitt reduziert sich
zwar die entfernung zwischen der
schildkröte und achilles aber wird kommt
nie zu einer populistischen tatsächliche
warum das müssen sie sich selber
angucken aber das ist etwas dass
klassisch die die philosophen
beschäftigt hat etwas vielleicht
einfacher zu erfassen ist eine
darstellung in platons der leukämie der
ist und da geht es um den wichtigen
begriff des augenblicks den wir schon
erwähnt haben der wahre gott vorkommt
und bei klages und bei der niemand
und da gibt es also ein augenblick das
ist in platons de hallo parameter ist
seit 156 buchstabe die was ist jetzt ja
da gibt es da geht es auch um diese
bewegungs paradoxien und die frage ist
ist ein gegenstand keine ruhen oder es
kann in bewegung sein aber es muss
entweder das eine oder das andere
aber es muss irgendwie jedenfalls das
ist das argument hier
es muss irgendwie ein zustand sein der
weder bewegung doch ruhen ist
oder beides aber das macht keinen sinn
das ist widerspruch weil ruhen ist ja
nicht wieder es ist nicht bewegung und
bewegung ist nicht nur deswegen kann ich
ohne widerspruch den übergang zwischen
ruhen und bewegen nicht begrifflich
formulieren
ja also es ist kein es wert hier nicht
bestritten dass gegenstände entweder
ruhen können oder sich bewegen
das kann ich begrifflich nicht erfassen
sind wieder das eine oder das andere als
kann nicht beides sein kann nicht beides
sein aber was ist ein zustand von nicht
mehr ruhen oder noch nicht in bewegung
sein dass ich meine
konkret kann man sich das problemlos
vorstellen aber wie soll das jetzt
begrifflich sein also man kann den
zeitabschnitt immer enger eingrenzen
also zwischen ruhen
zwischen den derzeit wohl wo der
gegenstand rot und und danach den
nachfolgenden zeitabschnitt wo es sich
bewegt aber irgendwo egal wie wie stark
man diese die schwelle komprimiert kommt
man auf einen zeitpunkt wo oder wann
kommen gar nicht also veränderung lässt
sich gar nicht konzipiert also das ist
mehr oder weniger das argument es heißt
dann im parlament ist das ist ein das
wunderbare ist der augenblick denn das
augenblickliche scheint der gleichen
etwas anzudeuten dass von ihm aus etwas
über
in eins von beiden also holen oder
bewegen
denn aus der ruhe geht nichts noch
während des hohen es über noch aus der
bewegung während es bewegt sein sondern
dieses wunderbare wesen der augenblick
liegt zwischen der bewegung und der ruhe
alles außer einer zeit sei außerdem der
augenblick also ob sie das argument
überzeugen finden oder nicht können wir
offen lassen und das ist ja darum geht
es mir weniger
es ist ein klassischer topos in der
philosophie die frage kann man bewegung
überhaupt begrifflich erfassen und da
insbesondere im zusammenhang mit dem
augenblick bei der augenblick hier in
diesen platonischen dialog ist das was
nicht in der zeit ist das ist der punkt
er sagte es ist außerhalb der zeit
und sie erinnern sich schon bei
kicker.de haben wir diesen gedanken dass
das der augenblick auch in dem man sich
an jesus erinnert oder was auch immer
außerhalb der geschichte ist es in jesus
ist nicht teil der geschichte sondern
steht außerhalb also das erlösende ist
gerade nicht verbunden mit fortschritt
sondern ist in ausdrücklich als kirche
dort verwendet den begriff augenblick
gerade auch in diesem sinne also wie es
scheint ein paar manager scom als als
ort als nicht zeitlicher ort und auch
jenseits der der begrifflichkeit also
das sind die das sind klassische
beispiele möglicher weise kennen sie
schon das ist schon wichtig also wenn
sie sich mit diesen werde sowieso
auseinandersetzen beschaffen
beschäftigen wollen
es ist nicht so an
hat ein bisschen die tendenz glaube ich
zu denken
es gibt heute die philosophie schreitet
voran und wird immer besser und wir
klären immer mehr fragen so ist es nicht
also philosophie ist und war schon immer
die elektrisch in dem sinne dass es
gerade nicht um antworten ging sondern
um den kampf mit fragen und die frage
hier ist was ist heute in der in einer
natur in naturwissenschaftlich
durchtränkten welt wie meine wegen in
der antike wo die naturwissenschaft
gewissermaßen vielleicht nicht so weit
fortgeschritten war
die frage ist was ist begrifflich
veränderung ja okay das ist das eine das
andere was bei khan vorkommt und auch
wichtig ist ist die simple frage also
was ich schon im zusammenhang mit leuten
nichts erwähnt hatte kann man überhaupt
sich begrifflich mit der welt
auseinandersetzen
in der form dass das wirklich alles
erfasst wird
wenn sie sich erinnern bei kant gerade
auch bei kant ganz sagt die arithmetik
ist nicht begrifflich oder nicht nur
begrifflich weil die arithmetik also 1
bis 12
3+ treu ist das beruht darauf dass ich
eine zitat anschauung habe von
gegenständen äpfeln fingern irgendwas
die ich dann zählen kann also einem
zählbarer gegenstand ist für kant eben
nicht etwas was rein begrifflich ist das
ist kann es argument und eine art und
weise wie er das untermauert ist in
seinen ausführungen zur sogenannten
orientierung also orientierung in der
philosophie ist beispielsweise oben
unten rechts links vorher nachher diese
orientierungs bezeichnungen so kalt und
so vielleicht auch andere in der
philosophie sind zwingend immer außer
begrifflich also kann nimmt das beispiel
von zwei handschuhen
man stelle sich zwei idealisierte
handschuhe forum rechts und links die in
allen aspekten identisch sind
nur ist passt ein handschuh auf die
rechte hand und ein handschuh auf die
linke hand und umgekehrt nicht
ja das ist jetzt leibnitz argument
wiederholt also leuten jetzt würde dann
was er könnte dann sagen ja ok aber in
der realität aber eigentlich könnte
hätte man schon genügend begriffe um die
handschuhe voneinander zu unterscheiden
weil die irgendwie in der herstellung
anders ausfallen aber das ist nicht das
sind gedanken experiment und kamps
gedankenexperiment ist unterstellt man
hätte zwei absolut identisch
das heißt alle allgemein begriffe die
man darauf anwenden könnte von der größe
farbe material und sofort angenommen
die einzige unterschied sei rechts und
links rum dann ist diese unterscheidung
keine begriffliche mehr weil rechts und
links gibt es nur weil ich da bin
also das ist die subjektive unterschied
ja alle anderen merkmale groß klein blau
baumwolle leder irgend sowas also dessen
das sind allgemeine begriffe die mit
meinem standpunkt nichts zu tun haben
aber rechts und links kann ich nur dann
zu schreiben dann nicht wenn ihr auch da
bin wenn ich der betrachtende das
betrachten das objekt ist vorhanden und
unterscheide zwischen rechts und links
ja also das ist kein argument gegen
wales bei leibnitz wie gesagt leibnitz
war der meinung dass alles sich
begrifflich subsumieren lässt kann sagt
nein ist nicht so da braucht man schon
anschauung und anschauung ist das was
ein subjektiver tatsächlich vorhandener
menschen 8 also ob das jetzt stimmt oder
ist eine andere frage aber das ist
ebenfalls ganz ansatz und das ist der
grund warum kann so auch die arithmetik
ist kein gutes beispiel für die restlose
erkennbarkeit
weil gerade die arithmetik darauf beruht
dass sich gegenstände abzählen kann und
gegenstände ab das abzählen von
gegenständen also hier sind dinge und da
ist ein ding unterbrochen das ist etwas
was von meinen von mir abhängt also
abzählen kann nur ein subjekt nicht ein
begriff ja das ist ein argument
ok jetzt eine fußnote dazu obwohl kann
diesen diesen ansatz vor dringend ist er
trotzdem letztendlich ein begriff mensch
der macht halt ein bisschen anders
er sagt und das ist ein tanz kritischer
transzendent alles muss ganz wie die
welt an sich ist können wir nicht
unbedingt wissen aber die instrumente
mit denen wir diese welt erkennen
die sind schon allgemein also die
allgemeinheit bekannt residiert in
meinem begriffs instrumentarium
ich kann zwar nicht sagen dass meine
begriffe unbedingt der außenwelt
korrespondieren aber diese mit dieser
frage müssen wir uns nicht weiter quälen
weil wir sagen können ist egal also für
alle menschen gilt ich erkenne nur mit
diesen kategorien mit den kategorien der
des verstandes beispielsweise kausalität
also die an dem viele hatten juden und
andere hatten leibnitz attackiert wegen
dem satz vom zureichenden grunde wie
willst du wissen lieber leibnitz das
alles eine ursache hat und was wie sieht
überhaupt eine ursache aus also ich
ungesagt gegenüber leibnitz
kausalität sehr schön aber aber wie soll
ich das jetzt wahrnehmen oder wo ist das
ich weiß ich wahrnehme ist nicht immer
nur eine folge als ihnen derzeit also
ist top steht auf dem herd irgendwann
kocht das wasser okay aber das ist eine
abfolge wo ist da die kausalität das ist
jungs frage antwort darauf ist ja gut
das mag schon sein also diese die
wesentlichen aspekte der außenwelt
können wir in der tat nicht wahrnehmen
wir wissen nicht ob das was in unseren
köpfen drin ist halt wirklich 100
prozent dem entspricht was da draußen
ist wissen wir nicht aber wir wissen
schon dass wir die instrumente mit denen
wir das erfassen alle miteinander teilen
und das sind begriffliche instrument vor
allem in dem fall qualität also für kant
ist die kausalität einfach eine
betrachtungsweise auf die wir aber nicht
verzichten können also das haben wir
alles gut also etwas ähnliches ein
vergleichbarer ansatz hat dann auch mit
gestein der folge wittgensteins
tractatus aber letztendlich wie gesagt
wickel stein oder frühere gesteinigt der
spätere der vögel wittgenstein und kann
befinden sich letztendlich doch bei den
begriff menschen und das ist das was
abgelehnt wird in dieser mächtigen
tradition
ende des 19 jahrhunderts und anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts begonnen mit
nietzsche wahrscheinlich doch ok und in
dieser tradition hier geht es kommen
jetzt endlich zu
demenz begriff das bild ist in der
gegend tradition die tradition gegen
begrifflichkeit und gegen nationalismus
wird die frage nach der gewissheit
anders beantwortet und hier vor allem
mit dem mit der vorstellung des bildes
und da noch mal die frage also was ist
gewissheit für den platonischen ist
gewissheit also ich bin sicher oder bin
sicher dass sie sicher sein kann weil
eben nachgewiesen nachgewiesenermaßen
ist die welt so wie meine gedanken und
diese kontinuität zwischen meine
gedanken und der welt lässt sich
beweisen belegt sich beispielsweise vor
allem in der mathematik oder hektik bei
den gegnern
aber die sagen eure ganz neuer ganzes
spiel mit begriffen ist
das können also die wichtigsten sachen
die veränderung orientierung kausalität
und so weiter
das könnt ihr alle das sind alles nur
unterstellungen
das hat ihr klar hat ihr das in euren
köpfen aber wohl wo ist da ist das ist
keine gewissheit
die einzige gewissheit sagen die gegner
die gewiss einzige gewissheit ist das
sehr schöne gedankenspiele habt also ihr
könnt mit eurer begrifflichkeit
wunderbar spielen und sicherlich auch
wenn vieles in der welt erreichen aber
ist das jetzt gewissheit im
philosophischen fragen die gegner
das einzige was sagen die gegner
über das unbestreitbar ist sind die
unmittelbaren empfindungen ja also was
in meinen kopf hinein strömt meine
wahrnehmung klar was ich diese
wahrnehmungen mögen unsystematisch und
frauen los sein und sobald ich anfange
aus den wahrnehmungen heraus andere
angebliche äußerungen abzuleiten dann
begebe ich mich auch auf dünnem eis
ja also eine wahrnehmung ist wirklich
nur eine wahrnehmung und das ist nur ein
bild ja ein beet ist nicht also bei den
begriffen hat man als ausgangspunkt
bestimmte daten die man dann logisch
miteinander verknüpft und daraus folgert
man zustände die man wovon man behauptet
dass ist das was existiert es ist so
aber bei bildern ist das anderes bild
das sind nur vergängliche ständig sich
ändernden sinnliche poster also da aber
das ist die gewissheit das kann ich
nicht bestreiten
es gibt kein also für mich jedenfalls
natürlich kann ich alle halluzinationen
oder
oder was auch immer haben aber auch das
ist gewissermaßen eine realität also was
ich nicht jetzt bestreiten kann ist das
was ich in meinem blickfeld hier
wahrnehmen und was ich höre und was ich
riechen kann
und sonst verspüre also das sind alles
bilder klar ich werde ich werde dann
weitergehen und daraus folgern ja es ist
15 uhr am 12 dezember und so weiter also
lauter solche sachen werde ich werde ich
schon folge war das sind folgerungen
dass das man dass der geist oder der
mensch ableitet aus grund gewissheiten
ist schon klar aber die frage ist was
und das mag stimmen oder nicht aber die
frage ist was ist die gewissheit und die
gegner von den nationalistischen ansatz
sagen die die grund gewissheit ist wie
gesagt der art eines bildes nicht derart
eines begriff ist okay wenn das so ist
also wenn wir von wenn die letzte
gewissheit bildhafte ist dann haben wir
eine ganz andere struktur von von
wahrheit und gewissheit
ja
also verordnung ist es schwieriger das
jetzt systematisch aufzubauen weil es ja
von vornherein nicht systematisch sein
will
aber ich gebe ihnen ein paar beispiele
die dann auch wichtig sein werden
wichtig sind für benjamin hier steht
natürlich der augenblick eine
fundamentale rolle weil gewissheit wie
gesagt ist nur im bild und ein bild ist
flüchtig also geht es um irgend jeder
nanosekunde ändert sich das der inhalt
meiner wahrnehmung von ihnen oder was
auch immer sie bewegen sich bewegt mich
und so weiter also das sind immer nur
oder die bilder die eine gewissheit
schafe sind über anderes und gerade
dieses diese eigenschaft sich zu
verändern deutet hinauf auf diesen
gedanken des augenblicks also blicke
bilder sind augenblicklich bilder
erscheinen dann augenblicklich weil sie
sich ständig ständig in veränderung
begriffen sind das heißt von vornherein
können wir das kontinuum vergessen wo
der geist geist gläubigen viel und so
immer bestrebt ist ein kontinuum
herzustellen also das was unverändert
bleibt sagt der gegner
das ist eine illusion war ist es nur die
aufblitzenden augenblicklich
aufblitzenden erscheinungen
das lässt sich gewiss auch gar nicht
bestreiten
das macht schon sinn meine es ist ein
bisschen fremd aber es ist nicht
irrational wie gesagt die frage ist was
ist gewissheit nicht wie verhalte ich
mich natürlich verhalte ich mich in
einem riesigen netzwerk von
überzeugungen und erfahrung
erwartungen und so weiter und so fort es
ist schon klar aber die frage die
metaphysische frage ist woraus entnehme
ich meine es weniger gewissheit
und da irgendwas aus der perspektive
dieser philosophischen debatte gibt es
nur zwei möglichkeiten entweder ich sage
gewissheit ist er ist in den begriffen
oder ich sage gewissheit ist gerade
nicht in den begriffen sondern nur in
den bildern daraus fließen viele
elemente die wenn man sie dann verfolgt
wird das nützliches liegt auf benjamins
überlegungen jetzt noch mal ich habe es
noch nicht erwähnt aber es wichtig die
frage nach der geschichte also benjamin
wie sie sich erinnern stellt sich die
den engel der geschichte so vor dass der
engel nach also mit dem rücken zur
zukunft sich bewegt ja also der der
engel ist rückwärtsgewandt der engel der
geschichte ist rückwärtsgewandt nicht
nach vorne und die aufgabe des
historikers wie sie sich erinnern es
gerade nicht so die die
heile neue welt der des sozialismus
aufzubauen sondern die geknechteten
vorfahren zu rechnen also zurückblickend
was in der zukunft ist also die zukunft
ist eine chimäre wissen gar nicht
vielleicht gibt gar keine zukunft die
aufgabe des historikers ist liegt in der
vergangenheit ja und das ist etwas was
sich stark an ludwig klages ablehnt
anlehnt allerdings mit wichtigen
änderungen aber bei klage ist ein
klageschrift von cosmo konischen errors
wie gesagt also klingt ein bisschen
besser aber wenn sie zeit haben sollten
sie sich das anschauen
[Applaus]
dieser ganze anti platonisch muss findet
in diesem in dieser schrift eine relativ
ausführliche darstellung
ok also für klage ist die realität nur
in der vergangenheit was auch sie macht
also wenn bilder die quelle der
gewissheit sind sind auch ist auch die
realität das was schon mal war als bild
also zukunft ist da eine reine
abstraktion sagt klages realität ist
immer nur das vergangene das mit uns
quasi oder das bilder zu uns
ja übermittelt aber das vielleicht eine
andere frage klages beispiel für diese
priorität der vergangenheit ist also
klar das war fasziniert von von der
anthropologie ludwig backofens das ist
wie ein schweizer anthropologe der ja
gut dass man es dabei aber was was
hervor gearbeitet wurde von diesem
anthropologen war waren verschiedene
formen des ahnenkult einen kult ist
beschäftigung mit seinen vorfahren
natürlich und der grund dafür sagt klage
es ist eben weiters ist eine
wirklichkeit im gegensatz zum
christentum also das ist diese diese
ganze gegnerschaft zu dem der platte
nisten ist sehr stark auch geprägt von
antiklerikalen also anti christlichen
motiven und was dort abgelehnt wird also
klar gesagt die christen glaubten angst
ewige leben und unsterblichkeit das
heißt wir schreiten voran quasi und dann
sterben wir und dann existieren wir
immer noch im himmel oder irgendwie und
das ist dies eine eine bessere zukunft
oder eine perversion dieses zukunfts
glaubens die realität ist die
vergangenheit und aus der vergangenheit
kommt die wirklichkeit und deswegen
sollten wir uns mit unseren ahnen
beschäftigen
ja okay es sind nur ein paar beispiele
für das was nein ich gebe ihnen noch ein
letztes beispiel etwas länger heute ein
weiteres beispiel für diese diese bilder
theorie ist die vorstellung dass also
bild ist das was ich an was man an der
oberfläche wahrnimmt also ich nehme sie
oder diese diesen raum war als geflecht
von farben im wesentlichen
ich nehme hier keine ich nehme sie nicht
alles an automobilen aber ich habe
keinen grund genug bild vor mir
sozusagen
ich kann sie auch nicht als als als
geister wahrnehmen
ich kann eben bestimmte nicht der puck
das werden wir nächstes mal vertiefen
aber ich möchte sie noch abschließend
auch was aufmerksam machen was wirklich
wichtig ist in diesem bereich und das
ist eine ästhetische theorie die die
oberfläche priorisiert gegenüber der
struktur also die klassische ästhetik
darunter auch kant beispielsweise sagt
schönheit ist wenn die außenhülle
das in den geist zum ausdruck bringt
also klassische schönheit die klassische
schönheit eines pferdes oder eines
menschen dargestellt ästhetisch ist
deswegen schön weil die kraft und das
leben und und positive
charaktereigenschaften oder was auch
immer zum ausdruck kommen in dieser
äußerlichkeit ja das ist die klassische
ästhetik davon bewegen sich einige im
ende des neunzehnten jahrhunderts weg
und eine es gibt ein paar sehr
interessante aufsätze von vom deutschen
dichter rilke über den bildhauer oder wo
er hervorhebt das ist hier um eine
oberfläche geht und nur um oberfläche
also rot als bildhauer ist das
übertragen von oberfläche von anderen
erscheinungen auf stein oder ob die
materie gesagt werden skulpturen
verfolgt dem zeigt sich dass sie nicht
über die oberfläche hinaus und irgendwie
in das innere des dinges hineingehen
darstellt ist es augenblicklich hinüber
flattern von irgendeiner form auf stein
er sagt alles glück von dem herzen
gezittert haben alles größe alle größe
und die zu denken uns was zerstört es
gab einen augenblick da sie nichts waren
als das kürzen von lippen
das hochziehen von augenbrauen schattige
stellen auf stirn und dieser zug um den
mund diese linie über den liedern diese
dunkelheit auf einem gesicht vielleicht
waren sie genau so schon vorher da als
zeichnung auf einem tier als forscher in
einem felsen als vertiefung auf einer
frucht
es gibt nur eine einzige 1000 feld ich
bewegte und abgewandelte oberfläche ja
okay das ist eine extreme fortführung
des gedankens das bild ist also bild ist
oberfläche bild ist das was ich an der
oberfläche wahrnehme und europa gesagt
hier was roter tut ist das einfangen von
elementen dieser unendlich vielfältig
abgewandelten oberfläche ja also keine
struktur keine analyse keine kausalität
sondern immer nur die eine andere
oberfläche und dass die die das weiß ich
jetzt
dabei bewenden weil sonst gerate ich
noch weiter in der zeit
das müssen wir dann nächste woche weiter
besprechen übrigens wir treffen uns
schon nächste woche das ist die letzte
der letzte termin vor weihnachten glaube
ich müsste sein 819
ich habe jetzt diese woche versucht
ziemlich viel material abzuarbeiten
benjamin ist unglaublich reich halte ich
wenn man anfängt da im detail ist einen
gedanken nachzugehen
aber wie gesagt jetzt abschließend ich
habe versucht dieses nationalistische
darzustellen dass diese bewegungen
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
ablehnen wir haben aber immer noch die
frage und das ist ganz wichtig also zum
einen habe ich mich noch nicht sehr viel
gesagt über dieser diesen anti
platonisch muss aber dass weitere ist
das wie benjamin ich habe sie schon
darauf hingewiesen wie benjamin sagt
bild es nicht gleich bild oder bilder
analyse ist nicht gleich bilder alles es
gibt also einige bilder
es gibt dialektische bilder und leute
wie klages bekannter antisemit zum
beispiel aber das ist jetzt nicht das
entscheidende aber klar es ist in diesem
sinne durchaus ein verfechter von
amerikanischen bildern auch wie carl
gustav jung
und andere und benjamin versuch ist sich
davon abzusetzen und einen deal ein
dialektisches bild ein befreiendes
erlösen das bild oder bilder theorie zu
erstellen und bis wir soweit sind haben
wir noch einige schritte vor uns okay
gibt es fragen oder einwände